i'm not getting paid for this but
um i really i can't i can't recommend
these enough here's the way i think
about it um
i think i think we sell them for 16 you
can't get them cheaper elsewhere which
is fine however frankly like i don't
know about you but i don't really have
lots of time to just go around to a shop
specifically to buy one of these so i
reckon like maybe you'll save a couple
dollars
i think just get it here because it's
faster it's just more convenient anyway
if you want to go bugger hunting that's
fine now you can see there's a whole
bunch of shapes here i don't need to
walk you through all of them right sorry
this is a bit wonky let me fix this up a
little bit um
what i like about it is that it makes
drawing things really really fast okay
really fast so for instance you're like
i need a circle we did um we did like
circumference and area
a while ago and you needed to draw like
a quick circle so that you can use that
as a diagram right so off you go you put
it there
um you should use a pencil but i don't
have one on me and off you go
all of like one second and it's a
perfect circle every single time okay
and it's like that for every single
shape you can see um for instance
they've got there this is an isosceles
triangle um you can see it's isosceles
because of these two markings here
you've also got you've got an ellipse
here this is nice
you have a square you've got a right
angled triangle that's also isosceles
which we use these in trigonometry all
the time right uh if you want it to have
different proportions you can use this
taller one and that's nice okay
we did the isosceles triangle there's
the equilateral triangle and on and on
and on if you go and do general one of
the common things you'll need to look at
is statistics and you can see this shape
here it has a name does anyone know what
it's called that graph there
it's well it's a kind of line graph but
it's a specific one so if i put some
axes in here like
so it does look like a wave
this is called in statistics it's called
um a bell curve right and the way it
works is you know most things in life if
you think like there's
things like say height height of people
right and so
you've got some people who are really
tall and you've got some people who are
really short and then most people are
kind of in the middle here right which
is why there's a higher curve in the
middle showing that there are more
people around average height and there
are heaps of things like that right so
this bell curve it comes up heaps and
heaps in statistics
and that's a big part of general so what
i really love about it is that it makes
these shapes really quick to draw and
it's it's perfect every single time
what i dislike about it is that some of
the shapes are smaller than i would like
so for example you know this square here
this is the biggest square
right now yeah that that's
small if you if you're not putting very
much information on it like say you had
to work out um an area right so you
might say oh four centimeters like a
right angle over here that would make
this four centimeters as well so that's
got enough information on it and so i
can work out the area is 16 centimeters
squared if i had to draw this thing
right but if i have to do anything extra
like if i have to put constructions on
it maybe get some get a few angles you
know something like this get a midpoint
here a diagonal over here and then i'm
like what about this angle and this
angle and on and on and on it starts to
get a bit too small and you're better
off just using a ruler to draw a bigger
one um so that's a limitation but you
know by and large most of the diagrams
we draw anywhere in a hurry are about
this big and when you draw it with one
of these it'll always be very accurate
that's the great thing about it and you
can do it fast okay
so even though these are these are cool
these are nice by far the most useful
thing for us at the moment is this
parabola shape so let me move this down
a little bit
okay here you go so let me show you show
you how to draw a quick parabola okay
and it will help if you have another
color to draw your axes in if you don't
it's no big deal but it's more helpful
that way um i used to draw my axes in
first and then i would put the parabola
in second i've since decided i feel like
it's better the other way around right
so here is my graph
and i'm just going to trace it out
like so
okay
now when i take this away i'll have the
shape there but you can see they've
drawn in an ax a set of axes here right
and you can use that to help guide you
so for instance
if i put these markers in here
like so that's the 9
that's the one and i'll put a couple of
markers in there through those dots you
can follow along as well now when i take
this off
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
form the x-axis by joining these two
dots and i know it's going to line up
properly like so right can you see it
goes right through the vertex yeah so
obviously that took a lot of time to
make sure that it would exactly line up
and you can do the y-axis in exactly the
same way
look at that perfect it's really nice
excuse me so
that's how you would draw you know this
is the graph we've been starting with a
lot this is y equals x squared okay
there's your y-axis your x-axis and your
origin right
what's really cool about this is that
you can um you can use for instance this
point here right because it was drawn
to scale you can actually read points
off it so for instance if i go with
these points which both happen to be one
and one they line up exactly here on
this point one one
right
because if i drew up my table of values
right like so
let's just draw up a couple
zero
squared will be zero so that's that's
the origin down here the vertex
one x equals one well one squared is um
one like like we noticed and if you go
again for instance if i go two
centimeters over because it's a
basically a one centimeter scale here
right so two right now
where do you expect this to be if i say
x equals 2 what will y be equal to
it'll be well hold on y equals there's x
2 squared or 4. good so 4 should be the
value i'm expecting right well if you
measure upwards four should be
let's have a look here
four centimeters that makes places four
up there so if you just draw a few dots
across just to see where that should
line up to like this
okay and then you draw downwards
it lines up
fairly nicely
it certainly lines up better than if we
had drawn it by hand and we just kind of
roughly do the best we can
but the scale will be a little bit off
and you can keep going
it's great because it's very accurate in
that way and there's there's one one
okay
now here's what's cool about this uh
let's let's leave this on here this is y
equals x squared and let me give you
another graph to draw okay let's think
about
we did this yesterday y equals minus
x squared okay so i'm going to do it on
the same set of axes i might just draw
this down a little further
because i do want a bit of extra space
here okay so all you have to do is you
take your same shape right and you just
lay it on upside down lay it nice and
carefully so everything lines up
okay make sure the vertex vertices the
vertex of each graph they should both be
on top of each other
um hold it down nice and and firmly i
like to put the finger close to here
because otherwise this part of it tends
to wiggle around a little bit like it
lifts off like
this right and then you lose your shape
your pen will push it out of out of
place so i like to hold it down there
on the right spot make sure it doesn't
move anywhere and then
draw in
the curve
like so and look at that flawless it's
really good
oh yeah sorry
okay there's there's y equals negative x
squared and we established yesterday
it's the same graph but literally
instead of right way up it's upside down
that's the only difference
now while we're at it
so this is the first graph we drew y
equals x squared
whoops
there it is up there okay there's the
second graph we drew y equals minus x
squared this thing's starting to get a
bit crowded i'm just going to put one
more graph under here and then we'll
start a new set of axes okay
what if i gave you this
y equals minus x squared plus
four okay so we went from y equals x
squared to minus x squared and we
noticed that flipped it upside down okay
now when i add 4 like this how would you
expect it to change
which way is it going to go
now
you can you can test some values to see
right but it's actually going to go up
and down you can draw yourself up a
table of values to be sure right if i
wanted to move it sideways
i would have to do something like
y equals um something like this and the
the number that we change would be
inside the brackets with the x but as
ali said it's actually going up down
now how far does it go up it goes up
four units
okay and don't forget this is minus x
squared so it's my uh it's my frowny
shape this is the way i used to uh get
told how to remember it
if it's positive that number out the
front
can you see that yeah a positive is kind
of like a smile right it's like you know
it's it's this is the smile in a face so
it's smiling okay so it's facing upwards
right if it's negative
out the front
so yeah see there's a negative out there
and you're like oh i'm feeling negative
i'm feeling bad you know i'm having
negative thoughts so that's frowning
there you go and you can see we've
already drawn this one down here it's
it's like the frown in a face it's a bit
cheesy but it works so
i've got a frowning one and it's been
moved upward four units can you see that
so i'm going to put my parabola on
upside down
there's where i was before and now i'm
going to move up four units and
conveniently i already have four marked
on there see that
so now the vertex will be up there at
four
you see
okay so let me say it again i i had y
equals x squared to begin with right so
that was this original shape that we've
seen many times then i went from y
equals x squared to minus x squared and
what did that do
flipped it upside down so then i have
this one down here
then i go one more step and i add four
sorry there you go
right so i take this frowning one and i
move it up four units
does that make sense
so there it is there's my frowning shape
which i drew before and now i'm going to
move it up
up up up up up four units
like so
and there it lines up does that make
sense so now i'm going to draw it
so now that three graphs that's
that's definitely uh enough to make it a
pretty crowded diagram i'm not going to
put any more on there but just so you
can see that in relation to each other
it's really nice right like i said step
one your regular parabola step two if i
slap a minus sign on it it's frowning
instead of smiling and then step three
three
if i add four it moves it upwards okay
in fact now that we have this parabola
shape this template that makes it so
easy i could draw like 10 different
graphs all the same one i might even
just show you quickly can i move it is
that okay
yeah no yeah
i'll leave it a bit longer
these are one of the things like your
calculators these are allowed in two
tests which frankly like the number of
times i've had to write on students
papers like this parabola the shape is
inaccurate or later on when we have a
look at these things you know when
you've talked about waves yeah there's
there's this curve
this one here this one's really
important it's the it's the side curve
oh sorry sorry there you go that's
better okay um this graph also really
important in um in year 11 even in
general and so the number of times
people draw this wrong because it's not
easy to draw accurately we're not good
at drawing curves nicely um
frankly this just it's like giving you
marks for free basically because you get
it perfect every single time i think
you're kind of crazy to not get one
um if you want to think about this way
like say 16 that's like eight bucks a
year eight bucks a year like you spent
eight bucks going to dinner like yeah
that's right that's right and um just
for the you can do it perfect fast every
time i've i've used one of these i've
drawn thousands of graphs on this i've
more than gotten it back right so
you definitely don't need to get one but
i think
it's it's to your advantage to get one
like i said they should be paid me to do